let's go back to like a record like
bedrock or like a record like every girl
like how would you would you would you
guys record those together or would you
guys we recorded every girl and bedrock
together and once again i'm gonna speak
to the genius of wayne real quick
wayne
formulated that whole every girl bedrock
type [ __ ] uh
wayne changed my whole verse around on
bedrock but the end
was the beginning i think the beginning
was the end but he was like yo it sounds
better on a walk-in just [ __ ] that he
known from being with the hot boys and
[ __ ] like that he shared that with us
like he used to always
share that [ __ ] with us like yo i'm
gonna get on these records with y'all
like i'ma sell it with y'all i ain't
just gonna throw you all out there so
that's why he was on every girl he was
on bedrock he knew this he was in the
videos he was bringing us on stage with
him he was he was doing all of that
because he was trying to sell it so
really that was wayne idea the bedrock i
mean every girl video
with all the different type of girls
getting out the video like skinny girls
big girls small girls white girls black
girls this this religion this religion
that was his idea to make it seem like
we like just kept getting out the car
like yeah we're just going to be in a
factory with the car and we're just
going so drake nicki j mills everyone's
in the studio together during this time
nah not for every girl nikki bullied her
way on bedrock shout out shout out to
dicky she she was like no you're not
gonna put out another single without me
like because every girl was like
something that we just did
and she's not in every girl right no
yeah that's yeah every girl was
something we did and
uh
i want to say hollywood somewhere
or somewhere like up there of sunset you
know them like the hotel they got a
studio in the hotel i forgot it's one of
them sexy shits like on the
on the whatever long story short we did
it in there and yeah we was all in there
together that's crazy it was all in
there together when we did bedrock uh
when we did bedrock
lloyd wasn't under the marion was on it
when we first when we first did it and
they got leaked and i think uh you know
wayne on him [ __ ] with no leaks
so when they got leaked like they was
trying to like switch it up still use
the record but that's why when the final
record came out it was that it was
i will say this man
wayne don't get enough credit
for a lot of [ __ ]
like with the whole young money [ __ ]
like we was when you think about where
we was at with it like drake was drake
from degrassi and nikki was nikki from
the from the dvds and the mixtapes and
gucci and all of that [ __ ] she was doing
and i was me from the smack dvds and
mixtapes and all that but
wayne was wayne he was on the verge of
it was right before lollipop he was on
the verge of becoming wayne wayne right
right right when he became wayne wayne
a million record soul first week
carter three
he took everybody
you know what i'm saying even if before
it was artist bus and we all had
different buses
it was
[ __ ] challenges on my bus
you know what i'm saying and i give him
a lot of credit for that because he
didn't have to put us on the stage with
him
at the height of his [ __ ] you know i'm
saying i can't think of too many
artists at that time
of his
like
level
that was doing the [ __ ] that he did for
us